at this point if you've been with us for
any length of time you know with almost
100% certainty that when I come to you
and I start a story by saying hey you
know what
there was a rare moment of truth or
candor or common sense on fox news you
can be almost certain that it was
shepard smith and previously we've had a
bunch of these different stories for you
we had one where shepherd smith actually
did the right thing and explained all of
the different Trump Russia lies that are
circulating or another instance where
Shepard Smith absolutely destroyed in a
very good five or six minute clip the
entire Hillary Clinton uranium one
conspiracy theory we talked to you about
when the truth about Trump Russia
briefly surfaced on Fox News some months
ago and it was of course Shepard Smith
we've also played clips for you of
Shepard Smith basically disgusted with
Fox News is so-called a reporting on
Baltimore violence and basically setting
the record straight on what was going on
there and now thinking back a couple of
years I think this was actually I
remember doing this story when we were
still in New York City Shepard Smith
destroying the irresponsible Ebola
coverage that was all over the place so
when over the weekend I read Fox News
hosts make sense on the topic of the
government shutdown that we're now
dealing with I figured it was Shepard
Smith and it was Shepard Smith and in
fact Shep said almost word-for-word what
I tweeted about the shutdown over the
weekend and if Shepard Smith and I are
on the same page you know that he's off
the fox news script I tweeted wait so
Republicans controlled the Senate House
and White House and are responsible for
the lack of an immigration bill but it's
the fault of the Democrats that the
government will shut down and Shepard
Smith alluded to almost the exact same
point phrased differently on Fox News
let's take a look let's take a listen
back in Washington there is one
discussion
government shutdown of course with one
party in charge of everything a
government shutdown will not happen
right I mean never in the history of at
least modern history of the country has
there been a government shutdown when a
single party is in charge of Washington
hook line & sinker House Senate White
House one party in charge that's it
Republicans have it all yet the
possibility of a government shutdown has
escalated the problem is really in the
Senate and of course that was before the
shutdown actually took place which is
which is happening now and and
presumably might be resolved by the time
you listen to today's program we don't
know they control everything right and
they can't keep government open there
are some committed Trumpets who have
actually figured out a way to blame
Democrats here and there on my Twitter
feed relentlessly and they've come up
with this gem they're telling me David
listen you need 60 votes in the Senate
which includes Democrats because there
aren't 60 Republicans so it's the
Democrats that are shutting down the
government by not coming over and
agreeing with what Republicans want you
control the White House the Senate and
the House of Representatives and you're
saying it's the fault of a few members
of the other party that we're having
this shutdown now of course first of all
just because a few Democrats can
filibuster in one chamber that doesn't
mean it's their fault if you don't
negotiate with them but the bigger
picture is that aside from the Democrats
even Republicans couldn't get on the
same page with each other in the Senate
or with Trump in the White House and my
fear was that this would work that
despite the reality as I pointed out as
Shepard Smith pointed out that
Republicans control everything I was
really worried that the right would
figure out some way to blame Democrats
and they tried they tried blaming or
blaming or naming this thing the Schumer
shutdown fortunately that failed and
hashtag Trump shutdown was trending on
Twitter and there's a recent poll which
shows that more than half of Americans
said if there's a shutdown this was
before it happened more than half of
Americans said they would either blame
Trump Republicans or some combination of
the two only 20 something percent said
they'd blame Democrat
not to mention that there actually was a
bipartisan deal on the table that was
rejected but Trump after he said put
something bipartisan on paper in front
of me and I'll sign it he ended up
actually not going for that so I
actually hate covering this crap because
it's just a political football which is
why you know Pat I didn't cover it in
the lead-up we knew this was pending for
weeks and I didn't mention it because
the cable news channels have a countdown
four days before this thing endless
interviews and fake drama these are
political footballs immediately
lawmakers should not get paid when
there's a shutdown California passed a
law where if they can't agree on a
budget and shut down state government
they don't get paid they've not missed a
single budget agreement since but it's
not going to happen because they all try
to use these shutdowns for political
gain what is a political football but it
does have political ramifications
especially with the 2018 midterms coming
up in the fall and such things to see
how the Democrats have maintained their
moral high ground on this topic because
they're the ones that are in favor of
daca yes they're the ones that are in
favor of a clean ship bill Claire
McCaskill actually of is in support of
making sure that the military members
get paid during this shutdown yeah we'll
see how it goes for them and mattis
actually said listen this shutdown stuff
is not good for the military although by
all indications there's not going to be
any significant impact or maybe even any
impact at all to military operations
it's one of those stories that corporate
media foams at the mouth over it's
almost like anything you can put a
countdown clock on is really really
great for corporate media but we see
this we've seen this happen again and
again and of course it is someone's
fault ultimately the fact that it's used
for political posturing and tossed
around as a political football doesn't
mean that we can't objectively assign
blame here and to say it's the Democrats
when the Republicans control everything
is laughable yeah and a government
shutdown sounds so severe when you put
it in those terms but really it's what
like maybe ten percent of the government
that actually closes now most everything
happens our payroll company reached out
to me today and they said yeah so just
so you know like absolutely nothing's
gonna happen yeah in terms of payroll
like all the all the agencies will still
accept your tax payments we're gonna
file everything for you don't don't
worry about a thing so anyway a little
bit of truth from
Shepard Smith the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership